Aaron you told me you talked to large
customers about their challenges in the
cloud
s and there is one challenge that all
these customers want guidance on
regardless of your Cloud maturity oh
what's that
well it relates to technical issues but
the challenge they face is actually
strategic
[Music]
so Aaron before we dig into this
challenge what's your role at Google
sure I'm A Cloud operations Advocate and
I talk with large customers all the time
about how to run reliable workloads in
the cloud now many of these customers
are moving their practices to align with
site reliability engineering or SRE
what is this site to reliability
engineering
well there are many different
definitions but I like the one from
Google's SRE handbook SRE is what
happens when you ask a software engineer
to design an operations team
how would a software engineer design an
operations team
well think about how software Engineers
approach a problem they focus on
efficiency usually by automating
repetitive tasks they invest time into
Project work and they avoid toil where
possible it makes sense does it work
with the desired outcome with SRE is to
improve the system for stakeholders
instead of babysitting the
infrastructure the more you automate the
infrastructure the more time you free up
for engineers that means they get even
more time to automate the infrastructure
and so on I call it the SRE virtuous
cycle the result is a more reliable
system happier Engineers happier users
and better outcomes
all right SRE makes sense you said there
was a challenge that all customers want
your guidance on what is that challenge
right it's alerting to many customers
have too many alerts and they're looking
for rules of thumb to reduce the noise
without missing anything important and
as simple as my advice may be I've seen
cases where it could save a team months
of pain yep I've definitely seen systems
that send too many alerts back when I
worked in startups but how do you
actually fix that
so first I think we would need to
clarify the relevance of what we're
monitoring to our desired outcomes
sounds like a good start
and then next we need to think about
what should happen when we send an alert
who gets the alert what actions do they
take are they responsible for notifying
other people putting our SRE hat back on
could the response just be automated
instead all right so you mentioned
relevance and outcomes let's address
each of them and let's be specific about
the method how to make it work so first
relevance how can I tell if an alert is
relevant or not A good rule of thumb is
simply this does the alert warn us about
something that will affect the main
purpose of a system and what do you mean
by purpose
excellent question so for retail store
selling items for a driver services
website it's processing vehicle
registrations for a non-profit
organization it could be to educate
readers on a topic got it and does this
purpose include the user experience yes
absolutely so user experience is a key
part of many different types of purposes
for example users might abandon our web
app or mobile app if it's too slow so
yes we do care
so let's say I have a system sending
alerts today or I'm building a new
system and I'm planning what alerts to
send how should I think about relevance
for any event that you're thinking to
alert on consider does this event affect
my purpose and if it doesn't don't send
an alert but if it does ask can it be
automated only if the event affects your
purpose and the response isn't already
automated send the alert to a person so
let's say I have a workload on cloud run
and let's say I'm currently sending
alerts on individual containers crash is
that a good approach what should I do
you know I see this tendency a lot
especially in operations cultures that
are just starting to transition to the
cloud or to SRE practices and here's
what I'd say
if you actually need to alert when an
individual resource fails there's a good
chance your operations are very brutal
instead lean on automation like failover
and with Cloud run Google handles
failover by default then you won't have
to alert whenever an individual
container crashes instead of alerting on
individual containers alert on what
users experience
so what if built-in automation like
you're mentioning to Cloud run failovers
what if they can't handle some errors
that happen in our system
so if it's a common or previously known
issue you can configure Google Cloud
monitoring to trigger actions through
web hooks or Pub sub to automate your
own custom response you should check out
notification policies okay and uh that
leaves us with focusing on the users and
tell me more about that
right in this case we should alert on
this service not so much the resources
alerting on status codes would be
relevant to us if most requests start
returning an error code 500 there's
clearly an issue that our users are
feeling and thus this idea relate to
service level objectives slos yes so in
Google Cloud monitoring you can
explicitly set alerts based on the slos
that you make I see so if resources are
failing so behind the scenes it may not
matter it only matters if users have a
bad experience at the service level
that's right see we're shifting Focus
from many possible causes to a few
actual symptoms oh I like that many
possible causes few actual symptoms yeah
yeah fewer symptoms great all right that
makes sense so that covers the first
part relevance but you also mentioned
outcomes of alerts uh tell me more about
that Aaron sure so let's look at
everyday communication for inspiration
so you know the the expression this
meeting should have been an email yep
yep I think we can all relate
well sometimes at 3am paging alert could
have been a 9 A.M ticket so we need to
ask
should we be waking up our on-call
engineers in the middle of the night for
an issue that's not harming any
customers or that our automation is
already handling
makes sense
then only send the alert to the person
who should act trust that person to
decide to notify other people if they
need it that'll reduce the overall
burden on the whole team so let's see
how this applies uh in in my example I
had a cloud run service and we decided
no more alerting on individual
containers crashing let's look at what
the user cares about the traffic is
Flowing is returning something else than
500 errors the majority of times
now in this example who do I notify when
there's a problem and what do I expect
them to do
remember our idea of ranking impact if
there's no traffic at all I page someone
and say look into this now if there's
all 500s same thing see these are
critical impact events I need the person
on call to see if they can determine the
cost and I usually have some steps in
the form of like a Playbook that we plan
out in advance for example step one
check that Google cloud is not reporting
any issues step two check that the load
balancer is active step three check for
recent deployments and so forth got it A
playbook makes perfect sense I wish I
had that back in the day how else can we
make life easier for the person
receiving the alert well when you're
creating a learning policies in Google
Cloud monitoring add contact steel to
the alert to make it more useful to the
person on call so in addition to
Playbooks you could add severity levels
as labels you could use templates that
reference metadata such as the project
or the region so the person on call
doesn't have to kind of guess or figure
these things out the Google Cloud
monitoring docs actually show you how to
do this by the way ah great I will
include the link to those docs in the
video description all right so you
mentioned paging like using a paper in
the 1990s well not quite mostly but with
Google Cloud monitoring you can send
alerts through SMS slack or pagerduty or
you can use Pub sub or webhooks to send
notifications to another system outside
Google cloud and now what about the less
urgent but still important issues
those issues I would have to create a
ticket instead of paging someone but if
it goes to a ticket won't get worked on
like a much later or perhaps even not at
all good point but the engineer on call
may be able to work on the ticket during
their shift see the paging is there for
interruptions
so if you use paging sparingly Engineers
can spend most of their time working on
tickets or ideally on Project work to
reduce toil ah very good all right let's
recap what can I do to improve alerting
in my system today
alerts should be relevant to the
system's purpose and what your users
feel they should only be sent if the
response isn't automated and you should
try to send alerts for the service not
the underlying infrastructure as much as
possible and if it does need to go to a
person who do you notify right so if the
situation requires an immediate response
page the person on call if it's less
urgent consider creating a ticket
instead of paging someone so you only
notify the people or the person you
intend to act in response and then you
trust them to inform more people if
needed in Google Cloud monitoring you
can use the notification policies to
reach people directly or through
external tools you can add contacts to
your alerts like links to Playbooks
severity labels and details about the
failing service
very good I'll put the links to these
resources in the video description
thank you everyone for watching if I
have any questions forever know me
please put them in the comments also let
me know if there are other serverless
topics that you'd like to see in future
episodes I read every single comment
until next time
[Music]